altair ahnten nicht was ich hier gerade
sehe wie oft ikea monatlich gegoogelt
wird
alle männer müssen konnte sich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video da das letzte mal so gut ankam
habe ich mir gedacht die spieler immer
wieder dass fire loher game
da geht es darum dass wir hier
beispielsweise kann die west
eingeblendet sehen uns sonst auf energie
und bei dem sonst auf entsteht
beispielsweise 1,5 millionen mal mit
dass monat als wenn das ding 5 millionen
mal monatlich gegoogelt wird und wir
müssen jetzt halt sagen okay wird kann
jeweils mehr als 15 millionen mal
monatlich gegoogelt oder weniger als 15
millionen mal monatlich gegoogelt
eigentlich mehr oder wir klicken mal auf
hoher und da sehen wir kaliber 22
millionen mal gegoogelt und jetzt müsse
das vergleichen mit folge call garten
wird nämlich definitiv weniger auf
gegoogelt
jetzt haben wir nämlich schon den score
die mir letzte mal fast nie erreicht
hätten es mal was irgendwie so dass wir
total lange dabei hingegen nur eine
sache richtig zu machen oder dann die
zweite sache richtig zu machen oder dann
endlich den übelsten spor ausgang schema
wird definitiv weniger gesammelt als
kolb was ist china ein paar schicken den
später alter schwede
da googelt man extra unterricht so was
der planeten neptun gegen die new
england patriots ich glaube die mühle
patriots werden mehr gewinn nämlich 15
millionen mal badminton
ich glaub gleichviel badminton sagen wir
mal lauer weil das ist jetzt ok 450.000
mal die nächste sache psychologisch ich
würde sagen es war nämlich weniger mit
judo wird mehr als 90.000 mal monatlich
geburt das ist klar die nächste sache
die vergleichen des jeremy clarkson der
wird auch öfter gegrübelt glaube ich
nicht 12 millionen mal scd aufgab
city of god würde ich sagen hat weniger
und 210.000 nigl man sei jetzt wohl in
rennfahrer ich glaub mal mehr als die
oft wenigstens haben wir diesmal drei
geschafft
altair ahnten nicht was ich hier gerade
sehe wie oft die kea monatlich gegoogelt
wird ikea wird einfach mal monatlich 30
millionen mal gegoogelt ich glaube alles
ist weniger als ikea hanni west der so
most hype börsen derzeit aller zeiten
der zeit geht weiß gar nicht ob das
überhaupt stimmt er wird zwei millionen
monatliche google werden letztes mal
wurden die vier millionen mal monatlich
die grünen nicht einfach 30 millionen
denn der umkehr into the wild hat
definitiv weniger als 30 millionen alter
schwede ikea 30 millionen big bang
theory würd ich sagen so einer der
bekanntesten serien aller zeiten wird
natürlich mehr als 150.000 mal gesucht
aber nicht 1,2 millionen aber noch nicht
30 millionen ikea was ist mit dir green
victoria wird weniger gegoogelt als
bigbank theorie es habe schon in zwei
drei vagina wir diesen mehr gewillt
nämlich zwei kinder so oft wie kali west
wird weight loss weniger gesucht als
vagina
glaub ich glaube es wird mehr gesucht
nur so wenig leute suchen danach wie sie
abnehmen können great barrier reef ist
definitiv mehr als 74.000 mal gesucht
landwirt weniger gesund als raid barrier
ich würde sagen mehr
auch gott wer bei doch keiner mehr als
drei geschafft der mindestlohn wird mehr
gegoogelt als six nations genau das ist
richtig dann haben wir hier rost paul
wohl mehr
was ist denn los boll ich glaube der
rost ball ist so was in die richtung
hochschule football in amerika aber so
richtig sich da bin ich mir dabei ist
auch nicht long island ice tea wird
glaube ich mehr gesucht als bret hart
das ist richtig general motors wird
definitiv merken dass brad hatte mich
sechs millionen mal okay das belegt
gerade den zweiten platz hinter ikea
beachvolleyball wird weniger gesucht
aber auch in millionen- 40.000 mal mit
no beachvolleyball gesucht alter was zum
weg bleiben change definitiv öfter als
70.000 mal nämlich 240.000 mal jimi
hendrix weniger a
ich habe jetzt gerade schon gemacht dass
die rothschild family eher weniger
gesucht wird als die bibel die bibel
hatte nämlich gerade eine million die
rutsche ließ ihr diese ich glaube die
hatten eine bank irgendwann oder tue ich
mich gerade wie zu busy wird auf jeden
fall mehr gesucht die rothschild family
sein film also ich glaube da wird
weniger gesucht ja genau 135000
inglourious basterds glaube ich mehr
nehmen nicht 301 1000 sehr cooler film
big brother glaube ich sogar noch mehr
als von 1000 1 8 millionen torture
weniger als 1,8 millionen novak djokovic
mit definitiv öfter als 135000 monatlich
besuchen mich eine millionen mal da
haben wir columbia das wird auch
mehrfach gesagt ein bisschen länger nach
wird da wir haben diesmal einen
highscore von acht erreicht auffach ich
wollte mich eigentlich in diesem video
wieder klatschen immer wenn ich falsch
gelegen habe ich glaube damit haben wir
das wenn euch das video gefallen meine
damen und herren würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freund schreibt mir die
kommentare ob ihr genauso gedacht hätte
und wie oft sucht ihr ikea wenn ihr noch
mal so ein video haben wollte habe ich
ja schon gesagt mit der bewertung also
schaltet einfach ab